[Music]
if you're anything like me you like the
idea of reading but when it actually
comes time to buckle down sit on a chair
pick up a book and read you have a hard
time focusing let alone really enjoying
it maybe you've thought to yourself well
I guess I'm just not a reader I'm more
of an action based learner you know I
learned by doing but deep down you know
that by not reading books you're missing
out on some of the most important
in-depth and profound insights ever
recorded so how can people like us
people who aren't naturally bookworms
actually read books retain their
information and actually learn to enjoy
it well in this video I'm going over
five powerful strategies that will help
you not only read more but find that you
enjoy reading more than you possibly
ever thought you ever could tip number
one if you want to start reading don't
over achieve it's very easy to say yeah
I'm gonna read a book a week from now on
but your past is telling you're not
going to so in order to break into the
habit of reading you need to set your
standards almost comically low I'm
talking one page a day reading one page
usually only takes about 60 seconds if
you're an average speed reader and well
it's an extremely easy task but remember
it's just as easy not to do so make sure
you do it don't make not doing it an
option and if you want to keep reading
after you've read your daily page go for
it but the important thing is to get
that one page in
[Music]
tip number two is read before going on
the internet you don't need me to tell
you that the Internet is an ADHD
inducing place full of cheap dopamine
highs and shallow thinking checking your
Facebook Instagram Pinterest and reddit
before reading a good book is like binge
eating skittles before tasting a fine
wine the wine will taste way worse and
you'll feel too sick to drink it anyways
point being read books before your brain
is zapped by the internet a great way to
do this obviously is to read first thing
in the morning which brings me right to
my next tip tip number three is bunch
your habits habit bunching is when you
pair an already existing habit that you
enjoy doing with a habit that you're
trying to work on if it's a habit for
you to drink a nice hot cup of coffee in
the morning then pair that habit with
reading an easy way to do this is to put
the book you want to read next to your
coffee maker in the morning so when you
get up and make yourself a cup of coffee
you'll see the book and you'll grab it
and go by punching an already existing
habit with when you're trying to work on
not only will it be easier to work on
that new habit but the enjoy ability of
the first habit may even rub off on the
second one tip number four is try
audiobooks listening to audiobooks is a
great way to soak in the information of
a book while still being able to
multitask one of my favorite things to
do especially if I have to read a book
for school is to listen to the book
while I'm working out and if you enjoy
working out like I do this counts as
habit bunching my camera just overheated
or was audible as my personal favorite
place to get audiobooks and while the
subscription isn't free oh yeah so if
you find yourself reading at about a
book a month pace an audibles free book
system pays for itself I think that math
checks out my fifth and final tip is
change your attitude in this tip while
it may seem not very practical or
hands-on it's probably the most
important because if you self-identify
as someone who hates reading you're
building up unnecessary mental
resistance towards something you're
trying to do more of
that's dumb so if you start identifying
as someone who enjoys reading you'll
break down mental barriers and you'll
find the previous four tips a lot easier
to do so there you go hopefully you find
these tips as useful as I currently do I
used to be someone who didn't like
reading reading is not a hard activity
in and of itself because you're just
kind of looking and understanding paper
but in this day and age with so many
distractions especially because of the
internet it definitely is a lot more
difficult to
eliminate those distractions and just
focus on doing something a little bit
slower paced for a while while I'm
definitely not a bookworm right now
these tips definitely help me get to a
point where I'm regularly reading good
books and making myself smarter and I
feel a lot better because of it if you
like this video be sure to hit that like
button if you like videos like these in
general hit that subscribe button leave
a comment because I love seeing your
comments and I respond to all of them I
don't know why I'm doing so many hand
gestures follow me on Twitter I have a
lot of social media linkie Dinks right
here know right here if you don't follow
me on all my social media just follow me
on Twitter because if you want to ask me
a question I'm regularly on there it's
by far the easiest way to communicate
with me a better ideas TV thanks for
watching and we'll catch you in the next
video